okay so let's go a little bit more into
the hypocrisy of this administration and
how on one hand they tell you and they
were voted in and we heard this i heard
this from all of my good liberal friends
biden is not an extremist he's an
elderly man who will bring the country
together
but it just isn't the case that they're
the ones ushering in the extremism
they're the ones who ushered in the
extremism when they were using their
foot soldiers to burn down our cities
here is video of biden advisor keisha
lance bottoms there's a name keisha
lance bottoms
and she is making it quite clear about
what she thinks of people who don't like
joe biden the institute for strategic
dialogue which tracks hate speech said
after the biden speech there was a surge
online in conversations that said
biden's remarks singling out maga
republicans were interpreted as a
declaration of war against conservatives
and all the trump voters
well what i would say to that
is that this is what this amount this
maga agenda has been all about it's been
about distorting the truth it's been
about misleading people it's been about
putting out information that inflames
people and i just encourage people go to
the white house website whitehouse.gov
and read the speech for yourself i've
read it multiple times and what i see in
this speech i see words of encouragement
i see optimism i see a
commander-in-chief who is calling out to
all of us no matter our political
affiliation all of us he wasn't calling
out to the manga supporters certainly he
mentioned them more than a dozen times
and as a threat to democracy has the
president essentially given up on those
maga republicans some 70 million people
well what the president has done is said
that he will continue to work with
mainstream republicans that he will work
with democrats that he will work with
independents to get things done in our
country but this mega-republican agenda
this hate fueled agenda this
mega-republican agenda that we saw
incite violence on our nation's capital
has no place in a democracy and if we
are not intentional about calling it out
which is what the president did
then our country everything that our
country is built upon is in danger
how has president biden bridged the
divide what has he done really to unify
this country the latest quinnipiac poll
has some really remarkable numbers 69 of
both democrats and republicans believe
democracy is in danger of collapse but
the republicans blame joe biden and the
democrats blame donald trump again how
has joe biden helped bridge that divide
well we saw it this summer when the
president was able to work in a
bipartisan way to get gun legislation
passed the president has always stood on
the fact that he can work with
mainstream republicans to get things
done on behalf of the american people
but it's also going to take for all of
us to stand up to hatred and what the
president again continues to say it's
this magga agenda the president has not
called out all republicans he's been
very specific about this mega agenda
isn't it incredible they never tell you
what this extremist agenda is i can only
go by what the guy did for four years
and it was pretty pretty good right and
i say that as a guy that didn't even
vote for him that first time okay
so what is so they just keep saying it
they keep repeating it joe biden will
work with anyone you know what's funny
donald trump would have worked with
absolutely anybody and he did when he
was president actually we just posted uh
the full video uh is up right now on
locals and i think the rest of it will
be on rumble and youtube this week my
interview with jared kushner who's the
president's obviously his son-in-law who
ushered in the middle east peace deals
and also was a senior advisor and i
asked him about that and he basically
said trump was willing to work with
anyone to get anything accomplished and
usually they would just hang up the
phone or not take the call clip one will
be up on youtube and rumble today the
full thing as i said is up on locals
already absolutely ad free oh at 1 15
today uh clip clip one of my interviewer
jared will be up anyway listen to what
they say so it's these maga republicans
who are violent and they are extremists
and all sorts of stuff well i saw this
incredible compilation video check this
out remind me about the violent
extremists hmm donald trump and the
migrant republicans
represent an extremism
that threatens the very foundations
of our republic
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they did not recognize the will of the
people when they fan the flames of
political violence
that are a threat
to our personal rights
to the pursuit of justice
to the rule of law
to the very soul of this country they
embrace anger
they thrive on chaos
the willingness to engage in political
violence is fatal in democracy
more and more talk about violence
as an acceptable
for political violence in america period
none ever
[Applause]
you know it's interesting phoenix my
producer just said something interested
me during that he said it's textbook
orwell it's weird to see
in real life but what a great
juxtaposition of the language of the
left versus the action of the left where
was joe biden and all the democrats when
they were burning down all the cities
when i lived in los angeles and a mob
literally went by my house and people
knew where i lived
and all of that stuff where where were
they on that were they calling for calm
uh or were they screaming more about
black lives matter and antifa and
fueling the flame by the way whatever
happened to black lives matter did they
ever solve any of the problems oh it
turns out that the leader of black lives
matter i think he came out this weekend
he embezzled like 10 million bucks
so they are the ones who have used
violence and that doesn't excuse any
violence that may or come out of the
right right if on january 6 you did
something illegal and you broke
something you burned something down or
something
okay fine i i believe in equality so
anyone that breaks the law should be in
trouble
but everything that joe biden just
accused the magga the dark magga
republicans of is exactly what his foot
soldiers have been doing
you